Transcriber:
Over the last few years,
corporations have made a major push
to prioritize diversity,
equity and inclusion
in all aspects of their organizations.
But DEI is left incomplete
if you don't consider individuals
that have been involved
in the criminal justice system.
Involvement in the criminal justice system
can impact someone's life,
someone's work status,
someone's experience at work.
It can even impact
someone's mental health,
just as much, if not more
than other factors we think about,
like race, age, gender and sexuality.
It's not like we willingly ignored
this topic in corporations,
it's just a massive blind spot.
I mean, one of the reasons
is nobody really openly talks about this.
You, your own wife or son,
could be in jail right now.
You could spend every night missing them,
every weekend in a visitation room
and never mention it to your coworkers.
The other reason this topic
isn't really touched on in corporations
is because we're just uninformed.
When we hear that someone is involved
in the criminal justice system,
our first thoughts might be
"murderer" or "violent criminal,"
and that's just not the case
for the 2.3 million people
involved in the US criminal justice
system right now.
And the fact that we focus
on the worst of the worst
is why nearly 75 percent
of justice-involved individuals
are unemployed a year after release.
So the question for us to consider is:
"As corporations,
what can we do about this?"
I've served in leadership roles
across American Family,
including overseeing our corporate
social responsibility strategy, or CSR.
Like many companies,
we partner with local
and national nonprofits,
we organize employee
volunteer opportunities,
and we donate to meaningful causes.
In 2018, we launched the American Family
Institute for Corporate and Social Impact,
to drive change and to close
equity gaps across America.
And within that mission,
we're partnering
with experts and organizations
that are working to support
families and individuals
that have been impacted by incarceration.
So the more and more
we talked to these partners,
and we heard about criminal
justice reform,
the more I started to think.
What are we doing internally
about this issue?
Maybe we need to think
about getting our own house in order.
And the most obvious place
for us to start was hiring.
95 percent of individuals serving time
in jail and prison right now
will be released,
and finding employment is difficult,
particularly if you have
a criminal record.
Some companies will just
flat out refuse to hire you,
and even if you have
the skills and the qualifications,
once they find out
you have a record, it's over.
And this is a huge problem,
because we know that one of the best ways
to prevent someone returning to prison
is employment.
And in some cases,
employment is a condition
of someone's parole.
A colleague of mine told me
about a man she'd met,
who was released from prison on parole.
The garage where he'd been
working was closing,
and he was unable to find another job,
which meant he would have to go back
to jail for violating his parole.
He shared with her that he would prefer
to commit suicide than go back to jail.
She spoke with him for about 45 minutes,
and she's not really sure if anything
that she said changed his perspective.
Hiring justice-involved individuals
is not just the kind thing to do,
an act of charity.
It could quite literally
be a matter of life or death.
So for us, the fastest, easiest way
to improve our hiring practices
was remove any up-front questions
about criminal history
on our job applications.
We got rid of anything that said
"Check here if you have
a criminal record."
We then updated
our public-facing job postings
to indicate that we consider
qualified candidates
with criminal histories.
These two interventions were simple.
They required minimal effort on our part,
and I believe that other employers
should follow suit.
But then, we took things a step further,
and we created intentional partnerships
to make sure justice-involved individuals
were included in our talent pipeline.
Many companies --
and we're no different --
have partnerships
with colleges and universities.
You know, we recruit from a pool
of graduating seniors,
knowing they’ll have the talent
and the skills to perform a job.
But what we also know is that today,
many prisons offer
advanced professional training
on skills like coding.
As corporations,
we can form relationships
with these programs as well
and include them in our talent pipeline.
For example, we have an employee,
after serving time in jail,
that joined us through one of these
talent partners, in our claims area.
We'll call him David.
David joined us earlier this year,
and with the support of his manager,
he is outperforming his peers.
He is on a path to higher opportunities
and promotional roles.
By providing a positive work experience
for justice-involved individuals,
we can change what’s possible
for them and their families.
Financial stability
can have an incredible impact
on our day-to-day life,
and the support of a manager
can instill the confidence in someone,
for the first time,
to see themselves in a career.
Now, some people worry.
They ask us,
"Aren't you sacrificing the quality
of your candidate pool
by including justice-involved
individuals?"
Just to be clear --
fair-chance hiring
is about increasing equity,
not about reducing our hiring standards.
In fact, the Society
for Human Resource Management
has conducted extensive
research in this space,
and they've found that 82 percent
of hiring managers
and 67 percent of HR professionals
find that the quality
of fair-chance talent
is the same or higher
than employees without records.
To assume that because someone
has a criminal record,
they're not qualified,
is just not a correct assumption.
In fact, for so many reasons,
for so many reasons,
they can become your most dedicated,
your most motivated,
your most hardworking employee,
because for them,
the stakes are so much higher.
But we knew, for this program to succeed,
we had to take a look
at our internal culture as well.
We had to provide training
for our leaders and our employees
on the realities
of the criminal justice system.
Individuals involved
in the criminal justice system
are subjected to a broad range
of dehumanizing labels
that are meant to marginalize
and stigmatize them.
Instead, we use language
that reflects their full identity
and acknowledges their future,
not just their past.
So we say “justice-involved”
or “returning citizen,”
which allows individuals to reclaim
their full selves, as people first.
And so what's funny,
the more and more we started
talking about this internally,
the more people started
coming out of the woodwork,
sharing their own experience
and impact of the criminal justice system.
For example, one of our leaders
in our claims area --
I'll call him Michael --
he came out in one of our internal
fair-chance hiring webinars
about the story of his daughter,
who struggled with addiction
and was subsequently convicted
with a felony charge.
Michael was so moved
by his daughter's experience
that he supports ongoing education
for justice-involved individuals.
His wife volunteers in jails and prisons,
because they both realize
the importance of support
in someone's reentry success.
And Michael, he believes
in investing in whole people.
He doesn’t think that it’s right
that society would make
decisions for someone
based on perception, or how they look.
And he has become one of our biggest
champions in our organization
in hiring fair-chance talent.
Our fair-chance hires are anonymous.
It's up to them if they want
to share their experiences
with their coworkers or their managers.
But it's my hope for the future
that we shift our culture
from one of ignorance and blindness
towards the formerly incarcerated
towards one of possibility
and reconciliation,
and that this is no longer
a taboo subject --
that coworkers will speak openly
about their experiences
and their family's experiences,
and we can support each other
fully, as individuals.
There are 1.8 million people
in jail right now.
And you may be thinking:
"Is anybody in my corporation
affected by the criminal justice system?"
There's a very good chance that they are.
And you may also think,
"Well, I don't know anybody
that's been impacted
by the criminal justice system."
Well, at the very least, you know me.
I have a loved one that was
incarcerated for over 14 years,
and that was a struggle for my family,
trying to support him
and stay close to him,
but also move on
with our day-to-day lives.
And for 14 years,
I didn't say a word to my coworkers.
And that was a secret that took a toll.
When he was finally released,
he was so motivated
to find employment near his home,
near his family.
But he couldn't find anybody
that would employ him.
Eventually, he did find an employer
that saw past the worst thing
he'd ever done
and gave him a fair chance.
He had to move across the country,
but I'm happy to say that,
12 years later, he's thriving,
all because someone took a chance on him.
And what's true for me and my family
is so true for so many Americans.
For current employees
and future employees,
criminal justice involvement
must be included in DEI strategies.
So based off of what we've learned,
here are some steps to help you implement
fair-chance hiring in your organization.
First of all ...
consider the qualifications
for a candidate
based on the role
that they're applying for.
It sounds obvious when I say it --
hire someone for the skills
needed for a job.
But the fact of the matter
is justice-involved individuals
are excluded from opportunities
for trivial reasons.
For example,
if you're hiring somebody in an IT role
that calls for coding experience ...
isn't the most important qualification
coding experience?
It matters less that they have
a criminal history
or a gap in their résumé
for the time they were incarcerated.
Ask yourself:
Do they have the skills
and qualifications to perform the job?
If yes, consider hiring them.
Toss out antiquated criteria and methods,
and consider a strengths-based
approach instead.
Second,
make sure that there is a path
for career growth and promotion
for your justice-involved employees.
Now the insurance industry
is highly regulated,
and there are certain roles
due to licenses
that may be off limits
for certain past offenses.
We don’t want to hire someone
in an entry level
only to find out
that they can't be promoted later.
So make sure that there is
a clear path for growth and success
in your company.
Third ...
realize that justice-involved employees
may need help adjusting
to your corporate culture.
You want someone that’s self-motivated
and self-directed and autonomous,
and that's the opposite
from what they've experienced in prison.
Some managers have told me
that their justice-involved employees
didn't even realize
that they didn't have to ask
their supervisor's permission
to take a bathroom break.
So it's a big culture shift,
but just know, with patience and grace,
you can help your employees thrive.
And then finally,
just make sure that education
and training in your DEI strategies
include human-centered language
and antibias training.
At the end of the day ...
justice-involved jobseekers
are human beings first,
and jobseekers second.
If you nurture that human being,
just imagine the impact
that you will have on their life,
their families, the community
and your organization.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)